when you think about it our news today
our news is so dominated by President
Trump that it's easy to forget there's
an entire world with plenty of news that
we're probably missing out on because
everything's Trump Trump Trump well here
to help us sort through it all the way
from India is our friend comedian vir
das here
[Applause]
totally thank you for having me here
we're very excited to have you here so
vir you're gonna take us through the
news from the rest of the world yes you
very generously given me five minutes to
talk about seven billion people
yeah actually now it's FC now four
minutes and thirty seconds so we got all
medical welcome to the rest of the world
it's a big place there's a lot of people
out there that you have yet to meet like
they take my country I'm from India we
have 1.3 billion people that's like for
Americans without Florida you're welcome
okay so veer what's the latest from
India what's going on space program it's
amazing it's like NASA with less Indians
now last year India launched a hundred
and four satellites in a single mission
fun fact 96 of them were American
satellites so see it's not just taxis in
ubers even your satellites can't get
from place to place without an Indian
driver okay inference so veer the
relationship is probably more complex no
it isn't Africa Africa's doing amazing
things Africa sitting on 30 percent of
the world's natural resources in 40
years Africa's being is going to be the
largest exporter of diamonds salt oil
and gold do you know what that means it
means black people may or may not be
attending the Oscars but they will be
manufacturing them wow that that's
that's quite a statement
yeah dictatorship hey America you know
how sometimes you feel like you're
living under the dictatorship for your
leaders just making irrational decisions
yeah well guess what
so do these countries
[Music]
okay now wait a minute wait a minute
beer that's supposed to make us feel
better yes you're not alone America
Gabon is with you
it doesn't help that Gabon is with us
alright here's something that'll make
you feel better the world has 7.3
billion people Twitter has only 300
million active monthly users so every
time Donald Trump tweets something like
truly insane 97 percent of the world
hasn't read that [ __ ] relax we don't
know to us Rocketman is still a song and
crooked Hillary is just a bridge in
Scotland okay well what about Canada
what's happening there nothing it's
perfect that's annoying actually yes it
is yeah okay catalonia ladies gentlemen
it's a country not a lady they're going
solo they're leaving Spain to form their
own country I'm calling it specks it
okay
specks it like brexit do you think
specks it will happen before a brexit
absolutely I'm Indian if there's one
thing we can say about the British they
take forever to leave a country
okay I hate to break it to you but you
got two minutes 15 seconds sorry is my
planet getting in the way of your
OxiClean commercial we gotta pay the
ransom Japan Japanese PM Shinzo Abe a
just won the elections with the
landslide victory and he's promised to
deal with North Korea himself so here's
the good news
Japan is now your ally I'm going to
break this down there's two teams it's
like the Olympics but everybody dies now
there's team Donald which is the USA
Japan and South Korea that's point five
billion people vs. team hoon who are
trying to destroy your democracy which
has North Korea China and Russia
that's 1.5 billion people wait a minute
it sounds like our side we're a billion
people short yeah and you know who
happens to have a billion people so now
would be a really good time to apologize
for a poo now I I didn't create that
character I just wrote for him okay one
last thing Conan I'm going to leave you
guys with this America has 45 million
immigrants but each year 75 million
tourists from the rest of the world
visit America so if you see somebody
just yelling at a foreigner on the
street just go back to your own damn
country chances are he's going to we
don't want your jobs we just want to see
Disneyland and destroy your democracy
and very nicely done
you